salut ça y est je viens enfin de rentrer
de suisse où j'avais passé trois jours à
lausanne et c'était vraiment top de vous
rencontrer on s'est éclatés temps au
spectacle après spectacle
merci beaucoup d'être venu là bas et si
vous êtes intéressé aussi à venir
mouvance spectacle et qu'on se rend
compte après les prochaines dates sont
le 10 décembre à clayes-sous-bois dans
le 78 le 31 décembre
je fais le 31 pour la dernière vidéo de
l'année à versailles alors elle factory
avec mon pote philippe roche il ya deux
horaires aujourd'hui je vous ai mis un
message sur snap et sur facebook vous
proposant de vous faire une petite
mentalisation par vidéo pour ça je vous
ai demandé de m'envoyer une photo ou une
vidéo de vous avec un jeu de cartes
complet ou non sur snapshot et je prends
quelqu'un maintenant au hasard alors
forcément vous avez été nombreux à
répondre
donc je vais faire circuler comme ça mon
doigt et puis au pire on va tomber sur
quelqu'un forcément rémy de grève
rémy de grève promis d'ici 45 je me
serais coiffer à fait d'accord va
envoyer dix mille photos en fait ça lui
rémy c'est fabien olicard alors je suis
pas plus coiffés que toi par contre je
viens de te choisir au hasard donc si tu
pouvais m'en voyez ton adresse skype
c'est une heure deux essais mais oui je
te vois je te vois tu m'entends que je
t'entends bien donc pas certain du tout
j'habite à leers dans l'offre à côté de
lille à d'accord c'est que je viens
jouer à lille le 6 et le 7 janvier ouais
ben hamza j'ai prendre des places 6 mai
face aux spotlights ya ce phare public
temps je suis un petit peu speed parce
que cette vidéo qui va sortir à 17
heures ouais donc comme tu l'entends je
suis tendu comme ça exactement voilà via
on va faire un truc skype et donc tu
verras dans la vidéo j'ai passé mon
doigt comme ça sur au pif sur snap et je
suis tombé sur toi et tes 30 mille
messages
est ce que tu vas pouvoir caler la
caméra pour avoir les mains libres ouais
âge exactement dans la charte qui clame
un génie pour toi un t-shirt avec textes
et diesse c'est un des premiers que
j'avais mis et la première fois que j'ai
sauté en parachute j'avais celui ci est
ce que tu peux mélanger les cartes on va
commencer par bien mélanger les cartes
là on joue tu m'as bien entendu ouais
ouais on a un petit élève mélange bien
les cartes comme ça
j'ai mélangé à l'empt arrive ouais mais
bon il faut qu'on prouve à tout le monde
que les cartes sont bien mélanger en
revanche tu volais youtube peu importe
ok ils sont pas dedans ok voilà on a
bien moi je vais préparer une petite
prédiction
ah oui que tu me vois pas bah oui
forcément toi tu veux tu me vois moi
jamais une carte à l'intérieur regardent
vous fait voir je viens mettre une carte
à l'intérieur de l'envelope et les
enveloppes
il faut forcément que vous puissiez
l'avoir est ici et toi aussi je vais la
tenir comme ça tout le long alors voici
le but du jeu tu as le jeu dans ta main
gauche c'est ça tu vas mettre ta main
droite au dessus du jeu comme une pince
exactement et tu vas prendre un petit
paquet de cartes 10 15 20 cartes un
petit paquet tu le prends tu lèves et
secondes tu retournes est le jeu qui
retournent les cartes et tulle et repose
sur le paquet face en l'air il retourne
comme sont exactement parfait maintenant
tu remets ta main par au dessus et tu
vas descendre plus profondément au delà
de la moitié tu lèves
qui est tu retournes et tu reposes ça
marche et dernière action tu vas passer
toutes les cartes qui sont en l'air
donc tu vois tu passes les cartes qui
sont en l'air comme ça ouais tu les
prends tu laissé par tu les prends oui
et tu les place sous le jeu face en bas
dans le bon sens
exactement et un ben ouais et sous
exactement parfait il ya maintenant une
carte au dessus du jeu une carte
complètement aléatoire est ce que parce
que tu peux la prendre et la retourner
ouais est ce que tu peux nous la faire
voir est ce que tu veux un thème de
chaos
est ce que la dame de carreau te plaît
ce que tu veux qu'on s'arrête là où est
ce que tu veux qu'on continue ou
allemands je veux la garder
tu veux qu'on s'arrête là et son acte
est sûre de toi
ouais ok je te faire voir quelles cartes
moi j'avais mis à l'intérieur de
l'envelope tu as choisi de la profondeur
que tu voulais à chaque fois tel un et
comme tu voulais à chaque fois et moi
j'ai une carte dedans y'a rien d'autre
tout fait bien voir quand même
il ya une carte et une seule carte c'est
l adage de chars au jeune homme
exactement cela est ce que je veux qu'on
leur fasse vite fait ou pas ouais on
peut aller alors remet toujours le jeu
fasse un pas dans ta main dont je garde
les cartes dans un nouvel océan c'est
tout on continue ouais en fait elles se
sont toutes remis dans le bon sens en
faisant sa logique
la démarche la dame de carreau aller où
elle joue au dessus alors de rançons se
prend là et mails dans l'âme et là dans
le milieu du jeu ok c'est bon alors
notre ami rémy m'a demandé qu'on
recommence alors voici ma prédiction ce
coup ci et comme tout à l'heure tu mets
le la main au dessus du paquet tu prends
un pied de quelques cartes
tu relèves turgis un tueur oppose celle
dont tu en mets la main dessus tu vas
plus profondément où tu veux tu prends
les lèves tu retournes maintenant tu
passes toutes les cartes faces en l'air
et tu l'aimés sous le jeu face en bas
avant que tu retournes la première carte
je vais te faire voir ma prédiction la
prédiction s'est su très peur c'est le
cadre de caruso est ce que toi tu peux
retourner la première car oui le cadre
de carreaux de rémy bravo mon pote ça va
ça t'a plu voilà ouais ça fait bizarre
on voit que ça lui a plu tu vois en même
temps un peu d'agacement 2 c'est
frustrant
bah oui tu m'étonnes et puis alors ça
effectivement tu as raison tu suis la
chaîne depuis longtemps toi ou pas ouais
depuis depuis du choix de vidéo à vos
pierre cros donc moi oui
ouais ouais mois de janvier est grave
donc toi tu sais mais tout le monde le
sais pas en fait de temps en temps
j'invite des gens sur la chaîne où je
fais sur skype et se passe des choses
que j'explique forcément parce que mon
but c'est aussi de vous bluffez de temps
en temps et voilà parce que ça m'amuse
et c'est aussi l'essence même de la
chaîne donc j'espère que j'étais bluffé
et j'espère que ça t'a plu ouais ça et
c'est bluffant
glossaire merci beaucoup la vidéo elle
sera 17h n'hésite pas à regarder les
commentaires je veux aller tu allais
checker saint john raid the radio
du coup bah oui g slate je partirai se
déplacent mais la voir ça dit il en
reste j'ai regardé ce matin il en reste
et puis envoie moi parce n'a pourquoi
quel jour tu viens si c'est le vendredi
le samedi et on se boit un verre je
t'offre un verre à la fin aviator et
demi de montage et voilà cette
mentalisation par skype est déjà
terminée alors oui c'était un mélange de
magie mentalisme mais c'était pour
changer un petit peu j'espère que ça
vous aura plu si c'est le cas n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner à la chan avant de
partir puisque le mental bugs et une
vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre merci à
rémy d'avoir participé c'était super
cool et à tous ceux qui avaient envoyé
un staff on leur fera de temps en temps
c'est promis rendez vous demain à 17
heures
ciao
là haut